l'ambassade de russie à kaboul a fait
savoir qu'elle espérait pouvoir coopérer
avec le nouveau pouvoir qui se met en
place en afghanistan même son cloche du
côté de glad eagle poutine qui s'est
entretenu avec son homologue ouzbek
l'ouzbékistan qui est rappelons le un
pays frontalier de l'afghanistan
les deux hommes ont dit suivre la
situation de très près et se sont
montrés favorables au dialogue et à la
coopération avec le nouveau pouvoir qui
va donc s'installer à kaboul
concrètement sur le terrain aucune
évacuation de l'ambassade n'est prévu à
l'heure actuelle l'envoyé spécial de la
russie pour l'afghanistan a dit avoir
reçu des garanties sur le fait qu'un
certain nombre d'ambassades ne craignent
rien dont celles de la russie je vous
propose d'écouter une réaction de la
mission diplomatique russe
aujourd'hui à kaboul on ressentait un
certain vide du pouvoir des coups de feu
ont été entendus et des cas de pillage
ont été signalées en ville mais la
situation sécuritaire ne s'est pas
complètement effondré l'ambassade a pris
un certain nombre de mesures pour
assurer la sécurité et à l'heure
actuelle rien ne menace la vie et la
santé du personnel de l'ambassade
les talibans garantissent la sécurité de
notre mission diplomatique et
l'ambassade continue de travailler en
mode ordinaire
malgré tout rien ne presse à reconnaître
officiellement le nouveau pouvoir en
place la russie observera dans un
premier temps la façon dont il se
comporte cependant il est bon de
souligner que moscou a toujours tenté de
favoriser le dialogue entre les
différentes parties en afghanistan est
organisé par exemple à de nombreuses
reprises des négociations dans la
capitale russe les talibans ne sont donc
pas un nouvel interlocuteur pour la
russie